we are here to present the next Awards
but first perhaps we should present each
other this very pretty lady just arrived
from Budapest where she appeared with
Richard Burton and Bluebeard miss Joey
Heatherton and this pretty man just
arrived from a line in front of a
theater when he's still trying to get in
to see himself in the well we're going
to present the Oscar for best
achievement and documentary film
production documentaries come in two
sizes short and long Sahrawis Joey yeah
you take this your neck all right
professed achievement and documentary
production short subjects the
nominations are adventures in perception
produced by Han Van Gelder art is
produced by Julien crane Ananda wit L
saved Junior the numbers start with the
river produced by Donald Wray sentinels
of silence produced by Manuel Arango and
Robert a Moran somebody waiting produced
by Hal Ronnie dick Snyder and Sherwood
omens
[ __ ] the winner is sentinels of silence
Manuel Arango a revered
ladies and gentlemen members of the
Academy we were rather shell-shocked
last time and I was my turn to speak
this time and I'm still shell-shocked
thank you very much
and for the best feature-length
documentary the nominations are Alaska
wilderness Lake Allen Landsberg producer
the hellström Chronicle Warland green
producer on any Sunday Bruce brown
producer the raw expedition Leonard Erin
Borg and Thor Heyerdahl producers the
sorrow and the pity
Marcel offals producer and the winner is
we're doing this
the hellström chronicle Wallen green
thank you very much it it may not have
seemed like it but this film had a lot
of people involved in it and I'd like to
thank David Wilbur and Mel Stewart and
David seltzer and Lalo Schifrin for
making it complete and and I'd like to
thank collip Singh for this thank you